[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber he is one of the biggest
names charged in a gang indictment in
Atlanta Young Thug but he is just one of
nearly two dozen people charged a
connection with YSL or young slime life
a seventh defendant chose to take a plea
deal this week that'll get him out of
jail prosecutors say that 41 year old
Antonio Sledge was a member of YSL since
2012 he's accused of threatening a
member of a rival gang participating in
a drive-by shooting and having knowledge
of at least one murder committed on
behalf of the gang the state alleges
that Sledge got money from Young Thug
whose real name is Jeffrey Williams to
lay low for a while Sledge is one of
several defendants who chose to plead
guilty instead of going to trial Young
Thug's own brother quantavius Grier
accepted a plea deal this week he was
sentenced to 12 years which was commuted
to two years of time served plus 10
years probation Sledge sitting on the
other side of his attorney listened to
what he and the Gang are accused of
defendant has personal knowledge that he
and other members are Associates of YSL
have either participated in or directly
committed at least one of the following
crimes in order to increase the
notoriety and reputation of YSL murder
armed robbery aggravated assault
attempted murder theft illegal gun
possession and illegal drug possession
and sales Mr Sledge how do you plead to
count to the charge of conspiracy to
violate the racketeer influence and
corrupt organizations act
and how do you plead to count 30
possession of a firearm by a convicted
felon previously convicted of a felony
involving the youth or possession of a
firearm guilty
now because Sledge took a plea deal
they're going to be certain conditions
that he has to meet in order for the
court to abide by the sentencing plan
that was laid out in the deal so Sledge
is required to testify in any trial that
comes from this indictment and he's not
going to be allowed to invoke his Fifth
Amendment right on the stand in return
the prosecution recommended 15 years
probation for the racketeering charge
with the firearm charge getting dropped
I'm here with my co-host and public
defender Brian buckmeyer joins me right
now so Brian that's quite a serious list
of offenses that the prosecution said
this gang is connected to why only
probation
Jesse probation seems strange for cases
like this and every defense attorney
have their own theories when pleased
like this are offered the DEA announced
these charges saying these men were
connected to a gang that had plagued the
city of Atlanta with violent crimes that
they had strong cases supported by a
controversial rap lyrics but the plea
deals seemed too good to be true to
believe all of that if these people are
so dangerous and as promised these cases
are this strong why the slap on the
wrist now don't get me wrong months of
jail felony probation and a criminal
felony record are not easy things to
live with but please like this when
people are facing mandatory 50 years in
jail always makes me think that they
have weak cases and need people to
testify to make them strong regardless
it looks like a number of people getting
pushed to trial for January 4th Memorial
will probably take please before that oh
you might be right I'm also here with my
uh other co-host former trial Attorney
Terry Austin I gotta ask are they
literally getting away with murder right
now oh absolutely no question you know
the bigger issue here forget the deal or
no plea deal the bigger issue here is
crime has risen 60 percent in Atlanta
and district attorney she basically
Willis promised that she was going to go
after this crime and instead what we see
here is a 56 count you know indictment
against these individuals we have over
you know 20 individuals who are indicted
why make it so complicated why not just
go after these individuals if there's
evidence of murder and violent crime
then go after that make it simple
instead what we have is all of these
people pleading out and getting a slap
on the wrist so I think the bigger issue
is there's crime and that crime is not
being addressed here two students in
California sued their High School in the
grounds of free speech after being
expelled and the U.S court of appeals
did not buy their argument the Albany
High School students created a private
Instagram account to share quote funny
memes that other people might not find
so funny or appropriate during the
2016-2017 school year what was actually
shared on the account were hateful posts
against black people referencing monkeys
and the KKK along with other racist
content when people call wind of the
account the students were eventually
expelled the student's argument included
a Supreme Court case from last year
where a cheerleader won a free speech
suit after being suspended from her team
for cursing on Snapchat the Supreme
Court ruled in her favor because the
post didn't risk classmates safety but
in this case U.S circuit court judge
Daniel Collins described the racist post
as a quote ticking bomb of vicious
targeted abuse that could be readily
detonated by anyone following the
account
another person arguing for the First
Amendment rights a tarot card reader
from Texas who's in hot water for
suggesting a University of Idaho
professors responsible for the murders
of four students Ashley Gillard went
viral on Tick Tock after pointing the
finger at University of Idaho Professor
Rebecca Schofield The Tick tocker
accused Schofield of being romantically
linked to one of the victims and then
ordering the execution of all four
students Schofield was cleared by police
in the investigation and she's now
asking Gillard for money to cover a
security system for her home after she
claims The Tick tocker's false
statements damaged her professional
reputation and also might motivate
someone to actually cause harm to her
family just take a listen to some of the
tarot readers theories and what she has
to say about the lawsuit against her
Rebecca's motive was she had something
going on with Kaylee whatever she had
going on with Kaylee was fraternization
potential relationship trying to be in a
relationship with her she was really
interested in Kaylee they may have even
fried rice and spend time together at
party at a party or something like that
the spirit said it was a teacher
involved in the murders when I was doing
the reading and by spirit I mean my
inner Spirit my inner Spirit that's not
bound by the body therefore even though
my body was not there my spirit can step
into information that my body could not
have when I go to court and they see the
evidence or they see how I connect the
dots then they'll make a decision as it
pertains to whether they want to
continue to live in blinders or believe
it if they don't that's that's I don't
care her body might not see it her soul
does she sounds like Doctor Strange
Terry Gillard is getting quite a bit of
exposure from her comments I think
that's pretty clear what are your
thoughts on that you know I think he you
have to think twice if you're in the
media about even interviewing her if her
statements are false and they seem to be
and if they are defamatory and that
seems to be the case then do you want to
give her an additional platform to make
her statements and if you actually end
up giving her a platform whether you're
supporting it whether you're fueling the
Flames or whether you don't agree with
her one thing you have to do and it's a
very delicate balance you have to make
sure you ask those hard-hitting
questions so at the end of the day the
viewers can decide whether or not what
she's saying is true or whether or not
what she's saying is false frankly if it
sounds like it's outrageous and to me
this sounds extremely outrageous as a
media Outlet I might decide I don't want
to even put her on the platform because
just having her there whether you
believe it or not is exposing what she's
saying it reminds me a little bit of the
Alex Jones case where he's making all of
these statements and the media is
following it the more it's repeated the
more damaging it could possibly be so
you have to think twice before you give
her a platform whether you support that
platform or whether you're trying to be
even-handed but Brian she's gonna lose
right I mean my she's not she doesn't
have a defense
I don't think so the only defense here
would be truth and if she goes up there
and somehow connects dots in a way that
the jury believes uh that she actually
truthfully believes this or it is true
maybe there's a defense the other
argument I can think of is this is so
ridiculous she could not possibly defame
anyone there's no one who's reasonably
gonna go and listen to her statements of
oh it's my spirit that's not within my
body but outside of my body tapping into
this and maybe that's not defamatory
because we all know that's ridiculous
that's the only defense I can see but
otherwise yeah fun to watch but I don't
think she's gonna win at this one this
is the case though where people are
literally grasping for any kind of
answers any solution to this crime and
she's getting attention this is a unique
situation so yeah it's a defense I just
don't think it's gonna work Brian Terry
pleasure as always thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign